the Joe Rogan experience could I in my
mind if people if you like somebody
right you see them you're gonna go up to
them and speak to them I just try to
gauge things on how I would do it right
for example on a plane with Steve Nash
this morning okay so Steve Nash I'm like
my she's like oh she watching my boy
he's like oh [ __ ] that Steve Nash and
I'm like oh [ __ ] that's Steve I didn't
speak this deep did you say hello no
nothing no okay I didn't feel it you're
not respected right right no he's a
great player
I feel John Stockton that's a little we
have to say what some people you have to
say hi to Rachel Dolezal Seattle
absolutely where was she
shoes I saw with uh I think she at least
one kid maybe another one she's just at
the airport we're online
no TSA PreCheck sexual now she's bought
yes you bisexual biracial she's oh no
she's not biracial transracial she is
black that's both transracial I know but
what I'm saying is she's bi so she's
straight and gay what the thing yeah but
I said hello said what's up amazing
forehead one of the best forehead you'll
ever see in the game my one order that's
what I would even order you want to get
the selfie no I saw Jesse Smollett took
a picture Oh
oh my goodness in Lafayette bakery what
do you think's gonna happen with him
nothing
it's amazing legal I think Chicago is
coming after oh no you think so no
didn't they say that they were an item
for the money for the money did they say
there's no such thing as canceled
coaching no mom canceled coach was
absolute [ __ ] Oh Oh Jay Simpson
proved it you know like when Bill Cosby
comes home he'll be on the road doing
[ __ ] stand-up while Kelly still
out his selling shows like Charlie Sheen
is still out here flourishing like Holly
Sheen ducked at all not wait a minute
not all he did get that age
some say the greatest endorsement deal
Magic Johnson ever sign I'm saying we're
not gonna act like his career didn't
flush
looks great take this age you gonna get
some movie think I was in my car the day
they announced on the radio that Magic
Johnson had HIV and I was [ __ ] my
pants I was like oh my god this is like
the beginning of a zombie movie we're
all gonna get it it's Magic Johnson with
all his money and all his fame if he's
got it I get it we're all gonna get it I
was terrified there's nothing wrong I
remember in my car driving yeah and then
I hear it on the radio I'm like holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] this is insane thirty
years later he looks great he looks
amazing it's great he's on TV telling us
why he left a [ __ ] Lakers a
night of the Lakers not once did
somebody say you imagine got HIV no I
said it that's all I was thinking about
every time see because he lives
incredible he does look incredible look
incredible yeah it's not even positive
and tests anymore wait what yeah I heard
that yeah if you give him a test for HIV
comes up negative because apparently
these protease inhibitors and all these
different things that they take - huh -
the different medications
you don't even test positive for HIV
anymore by the way
listen it was this older white dude and
I forgot what TV show I was on the set
of but he was explaining to me uh-huh
the whole situation with magic and he
was like the reason that they chose
magic was because they wanted to erase a
lot of these stigmas people thought that
HIV and AIDS was a gay disease and they
needed like a out famille I guess the to
have it to kind of erase that stigma and
to let people know that you can live
with it like HIV unless they gave it to
him whoa
this is what he told her this is not
somebody told me what they said to me
was magic I got caught up in some type
of scandal and her age right yeah and
we're falling before the scandal was
came out because the person that he was
wit was like some allegedly some bigwigs
child or something like that and so this
is they said this is what you're gonna
do so we don't ruin you now mystery Oh
before you take this in
he believes in Sasquatch doesn't believe
Sasquatch was real that just started
right now in this podcast if I asked him
yesterday he did 100% I'm not saying I
believe that magic theory I'm just
repeating what I was oh that is a common
rumor that's out there I've heard that
I've heard that rumor I think he doesn't
really have it but that it was either
that or but we just got done saying how
you read rumors about you that are
ridiculous and you know what the [ __ ]
and then you realize oh this is what
happens people just make [ __ ] up and
then people repeat the [ __ ] that people
make up cuz I can't fathom that he beat
aids bro aids was bodying peak back in
the day like mercury Freddie gone yeah
who else easy-easy e my downstairs
neighbor yes downstairs neighbor no no I
had it booked Charlie Sheen for 350
bucks booked him where I cameo Oh Oh on
cameo sunglasses on like what is
happening here what is what is he doing
yeah this dream he aged very quickly
it's like see he seemed to be fine when
he was doing two and a Half Men when he
stopped doing that show he gauged like a
hundred years old he had HIV we don't
know how its effects - I forgot exactly
we got everybody everybody's not Magic
Johnson here okay
I'm saying magic that by the way that is
why I say magic is like the greatest NBA
player of all time what because of that
he played 13 seasons in the NBA went to
nine NBA Finals won five of them one in
college came in won his rookie year and
went one-on-one with HIV and [ __ ] one
destroyed he destroyed the stigma of HIV
definitely did anybody that catches HIV
right now the first thing you're gonna
say to yourself is give me a magic stuff
I can live to anything of magic made it
yeah he's okay what a death sentence